it's been the deadliest 24-hour period
in the occupied West Bank in a year
three Palestinians were killed by
Israeli fire in two separate incidents
on Thursday and dozens of Palestinians
were wounded in Jenin nose of the
occupied West Bank tensions escalated
after the Israeli army demolished the
house of a Palestinian prisoner in the
city
nineteen-year-old yes honorable wife was
killed in confrontations between
Palestinian protesters and Israeli
forces following the house demolition a
Palestinian police officer was also
killed the funeral of 25-year old Todd
Ahmed ran was delayed till midday Friday
to allow his wife and two children to
come from Jordan where they live police
surveillance video shows by the way I'm
standing before he was killed
eyewitnesses told Al Jazeera that
bedouin was watching the confrontations
when he was shot by a sniper
a third Palestinian was killed in the
old city of Jerusalem one Israeli police
officer was lightly injured after the
gunmen shot at an Israeli police post in
the city
while Hamas praised the attacks the
Palestinian presidency described the
latest tension as a dangerous Israeli
escalation it said this follows the u.s.
announcement of its proposed Mideast
plan that was unveiled more than a week
ago
Palestinians have strongly rejected the
plan they say it means them accepting
the Israeli occupation and the status
quo analysts say the general mood in the
West Bank is that of frustration I think
that there is going to be a continuity
for a while some reactions because I
think the Palestinian public wanted to
show that the Palestinian people are
against this deal and that this deal is
compromising the legitimate rights of
the Palestinian people in their land but
I don't think that it will continue on
the long term later on Thursday the
Israeli army said it arrested a
Palestinian it says rammed his car into
Israeli soldiers in Jerusalem the attack
has left 12 Israeli soldiers wounded one
of whom sustained severe injuries it's
not clear whether tension will escalate
frustration has been mounting for a long
time and Palestinian factions of called
for protests on Friday against the u.s.
peace plan but if the previous calls are
any indication it seems unlikely that
these will materialize with ibrahim al
Jazeera the occupied West Bank